[Music]
all right all right let's bring the
vibes back
[Applause]
back in babies never left
vibes never left welcome back to off the
record where we talk about what it is
and we got our boy dumbfounded here
today
let's go how long has it been like a few
years it's been a few years a lot of
people don't know bart was my trainer
personal trainer
and he wasn't even like a trainer
trainer nah he was pretty bad yeah you
look like [ __ ] he was like training
wheels right
my manager just set us up like a blind
date like just like he's gonna train you
would you say that you are the reason
why you started barbell brigade i i
would take gret full of credit because
you were his first client
it was like it was cool we had a couple
months in and you know used to train
there was bolo from bloodsport oh yeah
yeah over there yeah the og the og would
people up there
you look at bart like that's not right i
heard he's an ass at 24 hour fitness or
something right well i think he feels
like he owns the place yeah so there's
times where like i'm on the bench and he
goes how many sets you have left and
before i could even finish he goes huh
he just kind of just pushes me off he
doesn't speak he doesn't use words i
kind of just got like oh sure he doesn't
use her everybody speaks for him they go
charm
they're not this is at the 24 hour that
would be hilarious
[Laughter]
be sick but he's such a legend that
everyone just moves out of the way
you're scary dude i've been seeing you
getting fit man what got you into the
the drive of it you gotta you know
30s you hit your 30s you got to like
focus in on your health and that's i
just got a little wake-up call dude
that's when i started two of my thirties
is that is that late that's kind of late
i think that's everybody though
a lot of people like dr dre started when
he's like 40 45. he got all jack plus
the rhymes got all jacked yeah dude
carrot top yup
oh he's scary he's been buff since i was
like 20 something big boy in the morning
oh that's lipo well that is yeah that's
a different thing okay
dave chappelle got all jack soup
in like 40. he was like 40 years old he
got all sorted i mean you either go that
route or you just get that's you know
more unhealthy what do we think about
jack guys though can jack guys really be
funny i don't think so really really
not that funny i think people just look
at him a little differently you know
when you see a buff guy or like a really
good looking dude on stage or like [ __ ]
this guy a little bit right
let's go
i don't relate to him like you already
have w's in your life you could chill
out right yeah go [ __ ] yourself dude
wasn't dane cook considered like a
heartthrob comedian yeah he was but he
also was seen as a hack too for that
reason by a lot of the comedians they
all hated him
all the girls loved them the other super
hot guy steve green
nobody's ever said that
[Laughter]
bart can you rate
dumb as
like you're you were his trainer yeah
did he make excuses is he is he texting
you
is it going this was like eight years
ago like nine oh he'll remember i know
him he'll remember actually this was
probably like 10 years ago straight up
yeah it probably was did he make
[ __ ] excuses yeah well dumb i think
really surprised me so it hit the
manager that hit me up
he was he was like super next level
because he was like uh you can you train
dumb i'm like wait what it was just a
crazy proposition and he goes yeah i
want him to get his cardio up on stage
so you can kill it at the shows yeah i
was very specific and i think in mark in
terms of marketability if he can rock
the show like tupac and have that sex
appeal and be jacked like he was just
like like he was one of those guys the
more he spoke
the more you kind of felt the vision
yeah like he put us on or like he it
felt like he put us through boot camp in
this independent youtube building early
on a lot of us it was like us anderson
like all these cats early on he was just
putting us through this boot camp but
like that like i didn't even know he was
having that discussion like he was
throwing me
into this thing
he would have these lunches with you
where you thought it was a lunch but
there's actually something being pitched
and i don't even know he's like hey you
want to get [ __ ] beef noodle soup
yeah yeah this is a businessman we're
kicking it and then he just has this
like silicon valley like vision you
didn't know what beef noodle soup means
for silicone
come on
we were just stupid-ass youtubers back
then we just thought he wanted to hang
and eat noodles
yeah but shout outs to dumb i think
we're supposed to train like four or
five days a week and he would cancel
like maybe once or twice every week but
he still cannot be out of time
40 cancellation not bad how early how
early would he go how early because i
know you'll go early
to get to the goal i think i try to
compromise with them so yeah like eight
or nine or something yeah but i mean now
i train every day and i go in by 10 a.m
every morning but i do it
every day i work out every day yeah dude
sometimes i get a text from bart and i'm
like this was six hours ago and i wake
up at 8 30 and he's like hey you down to
do jk this week i'm like what in the
[ __ ] did he wake up it was [ __ ] 2 15
a.m there's a lot of 4am text from this
guy about jk he's on vegas time you know
what i mean it's not a different time
zone it's just a different region you
know
at times different people bart has a
routine right you wake up and then you
you send you work out and then you send
out all your [ __ ] yeah i try to have
like a certain time where i do things so
or else i'm gonna lose track of [ __ ] so
you don't have to respond when he
messages you that's military dad ass
[ __ ] bro like that's the only way i can
keep track of students i'll forget do
you schedule jerk off time be honest
yeah for sure you do come on you don't
pencil it in come on no because that the
the
the feeling of wanting to jack off shows
up whenever yeah oh so go you're right
that was flexible that would take the
magic away he's flexible spontaneous
maybe you're flexible with the schedule
but like do you jerk off and you think
yourself i need to like work out the
jerk off like i need to get this to a
stronger journey inspiration happens at
any minute bro you never know dude
you're [ __ ] quiet
i was watching joe rogan recently i
thought you
because um
some somebody was on the show and they
basically said that like when when they
showed up joe rogan was like super
[ __ ] cold and they said that joe had
a friend say that his kid stayed in a
cold tub for 20 minutes and then joe
felt the need to stay in the cold tub
for 20 minutes because of his friend's
[ __ ] kid i was like the only person i
know who's like that is bart quan where
somebody's like hey do you know my uh
yeah my little brother he did this and
then bart's like i gotta beat this guy's
little brother
that's not me stays in it for 21 minutes
yeah exactly it's like haha [ __ ]
i like cold tubs that's just that long
bro 20 minutes is hardcore he said that
joe rogan was cold the entire time they
did a three-hour interview and they live
he's they're in texas and he said he was
cold the entire time till the end of the
interview we did a [ __ ] ice challenge
thing for jk party here oh and i think
julia won julia yeah yeah we were all
trying to keep our feet in this bucket
of cold thing for like i don't know how
long she was crazy i did cold training
and my body got my temperature got
hotter and i can't deal with the heat
here yo what what is that [ __ ] supposed
to be for though like what does it
improve i have no idea man i just saw
this old white dude do it
oh yeah yeah someone just put me on that
this is oh i do like the hottest new
influencer right now
they've linked me to this guy like five
times white people are trailblazers dude
we were trailers
i've been saying for a long time nobody
have you guys have you guys done some
whim hop [ __ ] though yeah
the breathing [ __ ] wall have you
tried this uh no i haven't okay i
guarantee this youtube a basic wim hof
like intro tutorial breathing accent
yeah just some intro [ __ ] you didn't
have to [ __ ] commit to the program
i'm not even talking about the culture
i'm talking about the one breathing
youtube it's a breathing program this
will this will literally do one youtube
video just walks you through some
breathing
so i have i have like shitty lungs
probably because i smoke too much weed
right so when i hold my breath if i hold
my breath right now if i try to hold i
probably 15 seconds i'll start coughing
you do the wim hof [ __ ] for like a
minute it's minute and a half yeah and
then he's like all right now hold your
breath on this one and i [ __ ] you know i
hold my breath like 90 plus seconds wow
and i'm like this isn't [ __ ] wow so
it works like instantly it's instant
it's [ __ ] incredible try that [ __ ]
and when you when you
experience an actual biohack like that
you're like oh it's pretty cool a
[ __ ] believer it's like an adrenaline
rush from just breathing and you like
oxy oxidate or whatever [ __ ] your body
and you get tingling feelings and [ __ ]
like that and then your whole
circulation is improved
like like your [ __ ] sword is no your
your throat is no longer sore you all
this shit's [ __ ] great for you it's
crazy i took nick out into the forest
during the winter was [ __ ]
i'm out
and there was a waterfall and that water
was ice cold because it was melting from
the snow
and that [ __ ] felt like splinters
shooting into your back and we tried to
see if we could stay in for a minute
that's different
that's cause that's constant fresh water
fresh cold water hitting you so it's
like it's never allowing you to
acclimate to a sun earth oh yeah because
the tub is warming up as you're in it
yeah but it's got ice cubes in it it's
consistent to the to the water that's
next you know what i mean why do you
guys have to push yourself like this
actually [ __ ] stupid really you know
what's funny i did it because i wanted
to get ready for europe because i didn't
i was i was always afraid of the cold so
i i didn't want to have a bad time being
afraid of like cold stuff i see today's
video is brought to you by feels cbd
isn't about what you feel is about what
you do not feel such as stress
anxiety all sorts of weird feels inside
your soul yeah sometimes these days
especially i think like people are going
back to work they're feeling the hustle
and bustle and whatever bandwidth they
had they feel like it's stretched to the
max
and before sometimes just having like a
hot bath would chill me out but now
sometimes my brain is just rushing with
all kinds of things and feels really
helps me out because i do the hot bath
and i do some cbd a couple drops
underneath the tongue
and then i finally feel relaxed and i
can go to sleep and that's so important
because without your good
seven eight nine hours of sleep it's
hard to convert your short-term memory
to long-term memory you don't feel
recovered especially if you train hard
so i really like feels because it helps
me get the most out of my night so i
feel good the next day and it's really
easy to use you just get a couple of
drops put it in your tongue i like to
put it in the tea because it's like i
don't know i feel like the field is
melting inside of my herbal tea yeah and
remember the last time you guys uh we
came over and we had a jacuzzi party i
think we should have a fields jacuzzi
party i feel so good we'll just like
drink some of that chill and tub get
some cbd and get ready to go to sleep i
think it's like a good nighttime routine
yeah and if you're new to this stuff and
you don't know how to do it what's
awesome with fields is they have a
hotline that you call in you could be
like hey
i don't know how to do this can you help
me guide myself through this so i don't
take too much and i know what i should
be doing and by the way what are you
wearing on the other side
[Laughter]
what are you wearing tonight you
probably don't want to ask that no but
you can ask us yeah but they'll guide
you through it which is what's really
cool so if you want to check it out go
to feels.com off the record that's f e a
l s dot com slash off the record to get
50 off your first order plus free
shipping feels.com off the record to get
50 off your first order plus free
shipping and they have subscription to
make it easy you don't have to worry
about it and you get a discount so check
it out our our buddy don that came on
here so our friend donny is like a
former special apps dude in the military
he couldn't hack delta he's yeah
[Laughter]
for this charity they did this five mile
underwater run
you run on the water so they're holding
a rock and it's him and his partner so
the other guy is swimming up here and
this guy's carrying a rock and whenever
he can't anymore he'll drop the rock and
he'll come up and take a breath and that
guy comes down and they do this for five
miles under water see when you're tired
of holding the rock and running
underwater you have to start swimming
with your friend you still have to swim
up you have to swim 20 feet up how many
laps is that they did in hawaii oh
because we played that game
yeah we played but not five miles
yeah this and i was like how long did i
should take this it was like six hours
six hours i'm like god damn we were
under water for six hours you still
couldn't make delta that's crazy
and he was like i was just uh what are
you gonna do to make it
because one the hard part is actually
getting
[Laughter]
getting the rock and then carrying it
because like you waste time grabbing it
and picking it up yeah that should
already takes like 30 seconds of breath
yeah there's a lot of additional work
that's being done and then i'm like
what's the hardest part and it was the
cold thing since you're so deep in the
ocean
um they were cold for like the
the last part of the day even though
they had blankets so they're going more
and more deeper that way they try to
stay along the coastline but the water
is just way colder than 20 feet than it
is what about boredom aren't they just
bored as [ __ ]
what are they thinking about
that's the [ __ ] like the active [ __ ] i
like it when there's it's kind of fun at
the same time you know i've been getting
into the bouldering lately oh boulder
yeah i go to la boulder yeah uh it's
really popular now it's super popular
everyone's on that wave every influencer
it is a new olympic sport too
yeah it's that public starting is not
this year though no it was it was it was
this year and it was crazy but they do
it like speed they like they go crazy
fast but i don't know it was fun like i
went one time i got really hooked
because i used to clown it you know i
just see people doing it looks nerdy
it's fun to make fun of when they gotta
carry their own crash pads and stuff
like that well it also looks like you're
grabbing dildos the whole time
like it's all sex toys yeah do you still
battle rap or not no no i don't battle
rap because i was thinking like stuff
like that will get you killed if other
people know that you're bouldering
you will get you no that's why after i
stopped battle rapping i was like i
could finally live a life like of
adventures i could have adventure
battle rapping held me back now i can
boulder like i want to
bro all the stuff i'm posting right now
i would get killed more bro
you carrying dodos to get to the top of
the mountain
why would you grab those
that's the thing about it it definitely
i realize when you're younger i mean
it's not even just battle rap when
you're younger you're trying to like
try extra hard to be a part of something
you know what i'm saying
and then you limit yourself to
adventures and [ __ ]
well you know what happens to a lot of
people always like oh that's some white
people [ __ ] that we limit ourselves like
that by not doing those activities
because we're like that's white people
respectfully bouldering is white people
yeah what the [ __ ] truth
when you put on a patagonia flannel
shirt and go into the forest yeah it is
kind of why people say white people [ __ ]
is kind of fun though they're like
paintballing against a bunch of kids and
you're trying to whip their ass no but
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] in different
countries too though you know what i
mean that's what cats don't realize like
over here yeah maybe like asian
americans like you know black americans
aren't doing it you know but if you go
to those places like they have all the
same [ __ ] camping is just called poverty
they got that weird [ __ ] like equality
and stuff in other countries
well that's why over here you can roast
some [ __ ] it's just named
differently right like mindfulness
that's just buddhism right
like camp branding right you have new
brands yeah poverty homelessness is like
different right like yeah like [ __ ]
rock climbing
escaping communism you know like
branding
escape rooms
[Music]
bouldering is one of the shittiest names
i've ever heard
rock climbing sounds sick yeah
bouldering is [ __ ] you know but
that's why they call it right bouldering
no the difference is the the [ __ ]
you're not attached to anything yeah but
it sounds like you couldn't make rock
climb so that's why you're doing this
yeah
how you feel about the name ping pong
as a white man
white man
that's not for us bro isn't it called
table tennis or the regular they were
really lazy as [ __ ] with that name ping
pong yeah
that's an asian sport isn't it basically
oh we kill table tennis that's our [ __ ]
well that's why we're not gonna call it
table ten it's just ping pong ping pong
yeah rebrand it's like china versus
china always it's like yin yang but they
call it ping pong
it's ping pong and asian like even in
chinese it sounds racist so in chinese
it's ping pong
i don't know i don't even know what it
means it's not based off is it actually
like is it
it's a sound or what's it like oh it's
just a sound yeah
i didn't look this [ __ ] up what the [ __ ]
we can't be out here saying ping pong
bro we got it we got to say table tennis
all we've said is ping pong my whole
life table tennis sounds wack yeah ping
pong it's ping pong bro
when you tell people i play table tennis
they're like why don't you just play
regular tennis they say table tennis and
olympics that's because you know they're
you know globally
politically correct ping pong is also
just what i call asian people behind
closed doors
when i'm off camera though that's what
he called barts and joe bro if i'm off
camera
otherwise that's like king kong it's
it's yeah yeah yeah oh i want to be the
king though you think that's just how it
is they just substitute the [ __ ]
consonant for
another just
like ding dong what's the origin of ping
pong yeah what's sing song oh holy [ __ ]
this goes deep damn bro
those are the worst rhymes i've ever
heard
dumb's like yeah i thought that was sick
like in 2001
i always feel like the asian derogatory
terms just they seem really old it's
hacky yeah it's so happy i mean
obviously like it's like somebody calls
you a [ __ ] i'm like are you a time
traveler or like you just sounds old as
[ __ ] like [ __ ] that's what i got called
a goomba i expect like a
70 year old vet to call me that exactly
but then like a young
white kid i'm like somebody called me a
goo like i can't even i would want to
laugh at you you know what i'm saying
the best one is zipper head
i don't even know what i mean i didn't
even know that [ __ ] until i like i
learned about new derogatory terms
through
oh
action i was like what are these terms
like wait wait wait what's the new
derogatory term for like uh synonymous
to a group aka which a korean right is
there a new one i don't know
the only one that still probably hits
hard is like if somebody says [ __ ] like
that's it still sounds very offensive
you know but but even that's but even
still old it's so old i can't get too
offended by that
is there a new racist oh we tell it
racist right now to update dirt
hey some new [ __ ] bro update your [ __ ]
where it is i haven't watched the
cleaning move in a couple years so he's
probably updating it we don't even know
he's making a new one i just saw a
trailer for a new one so he's like 98
years old right cry macho if another war
happens between america and an asian
country new ones will be made that's
what we need dude i'm jealous of asian
countries with their vending machines
have you seen some of this [ __ ]
yeah they got dirty underwear they got
not even they got cakes they got [ __ ]
everything spaghetti you can get any
anything bro there's one that has curry
rice yeah one of our favorite uh ramen
spots in japan you order through a
vending machine those are the best
and you got the fold out things where
you can like section yourself off and
sit at the bar and not talk to anybody
that's why i know that people don't like
that but i feel like i'm an asian person
because i would every vending machine
everything our vending machines are
pretty that's how you feel like an asian
prison yeah
i feel like an asian person because of
that
machines i watch these well i watch
dancing bacons on youtubes and i tell
you what i'm an ally i watch
i'm this guy a thousand percent that's
true
sometimes i forget how white you are but
then you crack or open a can of monster
and i'm like oh it's my white buddy
red bull
i drink russian drinks
the moscow mule here nothing but vodka
and they're three rebels a day and a
[ __ ] wwe shirt right now dude well
it's a double entendre shirt because
it's because
definitely you got to drink it in that
cup though right you have to that's the
cup you got it you have to does it
change the taste of the drink when it's
a metal cup
no it's just the branding of it yeah it
does yeah i think it does like that
water liquid metal
have you guys got that no no it's water
but it's in like a beer can it actually
tastes ways straws you know like i'm all
about the environment but paper straws
are trash bro paper straws suck dicks
hey guess what the masks are doing right
now they're clogging up the oceans yeah
well people want to [ __ ] about the the
plastic straws about like plastic
consumption but it's not
[ __ ] from straws
it's all the other [ __ ] that we use
that's all plastic are the masks really
[ __ ] up the is it ocean for real it's
a new one it's a new realization yeah
yeah there's a lot of masks
unless you watch see spiricy it's really
not about that anybody see that yeah
what is that about it's about the
[ __ ]
most of the plastic and most of the
things that are killing the sea life in
the in the ocean is the fishing
equipment it's not even just fishing and
killing the species like fishing lines
the fishing lines and the nets everybody
every [ __ ] animal species is dying
from being caught up in like to make
fishing line out of paper then oh yeah
can't catch no big fish no paper string
bro
exactly then they'll learn they need
dissolving
biodegradable fishing nets dude turtles
just gotta be smarter frankly yeah like
you can't be small they let their babies
get eaten by [ __ ] pelicans all the
time like they haven't learned that for
hundreds of years babies get eaten by
pelicans give me a break you know though
from kovid a lot of endangered species
are not endangered anymore are you
exactly like turtles we're in dangers
but not anymore now there's too damn
much they need to get [ __ ] dude now
there's too many white tigers too they
just you have to go you can go hunt
white tigers now are we just spreading
false information about animals right
now hey that's what the show is
literally hunt a white tiger right now
you got my words i was just tweeting
today that i felt i feel like i haven't
seen like an animal in a long time like
i'm not i'm talking not talking like
animals birds and deer
i'm talking about you know the rare
joints you know what i mean like such as
well you gotta go to see those i know
but it's like an ant eater
of all animals
well that's why i feel like i got to go
to a zoo or something like a meerkat
yeah but the fact that we got a gold
like a thing and two seedlings
in the wild in the wild like i would
like to it's been a while like when's
the last time you saw some [ __ ] like
what's the rarest [ __ ] you've seen
recently in l.a raccoons
i saw a raccoon yeah recently in l.a and
you were like oh [ __ ] it's a raccoon
uh-huh i saw it i haven't seen a raccoon
in a while actually that's crazy jaguar
in a cheetah cub playing with each other
oh you went to mexico play at the carbon
do they have a chain were they attached
to a radiator
[Music]
you